I found it really quite odd that in the
2016 presidential election there's been
very little talk about k-12 education
even though there are over fifty million
people in our society that are affected
by the decisions made by policymakers
regarding public education and I think
what happens what we've seen especially
in the media in the past couple years
there has been a massive discussion
around issues in education and I wish
that the Kent presidential candidates
would address these these concerns and
there's been issues around charter
schools and standardized testing and
teachers unions and pay-for-performance
there been documentaries such as Waiting
for Superman races to nowhere
the war on kids and so there has been
quite a bit of discussion around
education but I argue that some of the
discussion has not been as authentic and
rich as it could be with the media and
journalists often frame the conversation
around education is charter schools
versus versus again against charter
schools pay for performance against pay
for performance are you forced out of
assessing or you against our next
testing and I obviously believe those
are important issues and they need to be
talked about and debated but there is a
more important issue I think that is
that is under that is above all these
kind of these issues altogether which is
the American education system and the
structures and the anti-democratic
nature nature of this system and I think
we have not talked about the teaching
and learning practices of American
schools why is it that 18 year olds who
are about to go to college
half ask permission to use the bathroom
for example why is it that corporal
punishment is legal in 19 states in this
country why is it that children are have
very few freedoms and rights in school
there was a study done by Robert Epstein
a psychologists and and and and another
psychologist who found that
schoolchildren are put under two times
as many restrictions as inmates in
prison so they have very few freedoms
and autonomy in schools and nobody's
talking about this nobody's addressing
these these concerns on a national scale
and so I think obviously we need to talk
about Sarah's testing and charter
schools and the like
we also need to address the learning and
teaching practices of modern schools and
why is it that schools have largely
remained the same ever since their
inception in the 1850s so those
questions I think need to be posed to
our policymakers and I people like
Bernie Sanders and Hillary Clinton as
well as the Republican candidates I mean
Donald Trump has talked a little bit
about issues around common core but even
on the Democratic side I think there has
been an astonishing lack of discussion
and an agenda around k-12 education and
I strongly urge the presidential
candidates to discuss the statute
because you have millions of people who
are affected by these decisions and I
think the media has to do a better job
enforcing this conversation on to the
national stage oftentimes education
journalists have very little experience
in education or very low experience
actually reporting on the schools
themselves education is just kind of
like one of those other beats and I
argue that if you want to become an
education journalist if you want to
report on education issues you just
can't go to that beat from from the
transportation beat or the national
security beat you have to do a lot of
research and understanding of the
history of public education the the the
structures that we have in place
policies you just can't go into this
without having with that without having
a strong idea of how the system was
created and the purposes of it and I
find that most education journalists one
of the reasons why there has been such a
poor quality of education journalism in
the past past couple of years and
decades is because the education
journalists have not had experience were
in schools talking to students and
teachers and they don't have any idea of
the history of the system so I mean one
of the things I wanted to show in my
book school on trial was that I wanted
to elevate the voices of the students
and the teachers and the parents to show
that their perspectives are basically
not considered by policymakers that they
need to be part of this conversation and
the most important stakeholders which
are the students and the teachers need
to be part of this discussion and listen
to very seriously because their concerns
are legitimate and need to be put into
action I think one of the reasons why
yeah there is such a
can a position of the way we look at
education charter schools versus public
school center sustaining versus
notarized testing is because a lot of
education journalists don't have the
context of where these issues lie I mean
the issues around Sandra's testing and
for example charter schools are I mean
they're not new I mean this these these
battles have been happening for decades
and if you want to take the issue of
charter schools for example I am
somebody who is a supporter of some
charter schools but I've critiqued this
charter school movement altogether and
if you actually looked at the history of
charter schools the original purpose of
charter schools wants to create publicly
funded schools that we're going to be
innovative and given flexibility in
terms of their standards and curriculum
and and testing and if you didn't if you
don't know that history if you don't
actually have looked at where the system
was created you can't understand why the
the movement has been designed the way
it has structured has been operating
today and I think charter schools is an
excellent example because you can't I
think often times the media kind of
paints it with a broad brush I think
there's a lot of major problems with
charter schools the corporatization of
charter schools I mean for example
Success Academy and allegations of child
abuse and and and and other and other
concerns but there are charter schools
for example like high tech high in San
Diego a project-based learning
innovative school that happens to just
be a charter school and so it is not a
black and white kind of situation is
much more nuanced in the and the media
oftentimes kind of pits one group
against the other when I think a lot of
people who support probably public
education who support many of idea many
many of them I my ideas would support
charter schools if they actually were
founded and wedded to the beliefs that
we want to see for all school and
altogether